[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro des matins du
sénat la crise du coronavirus
contribuera-t-elle à renforcer le
pouvoir des départements en février
dernier une mission d'information a été
lancée par le sénat celle ci visait à
s'interroger sur le rôle du département
sur sa place sur ses compétences
dominique bussereau le président de
l'assemblée des départements de france a
justement été auditionné par les
sénateurs on regarde on en parle juste
après quelques propos introductif en
complément aux réponses du questionnaire
car nos voisins cités à l'instant la
sphère des régions est quand même une
affaire d'une grande improvisation
pour donner un exemple la région poitou
charentes dont fait partie la
charente-maritime je vous parle depuis
la rochelle est passé dans la même nuit
de la région pays de la loire jusqu'aux
alentours d'une heure du matin puis
jusqu'aux alentours de 4 ou 5 heures du
matin dans les discussions y lisait nous
étions raccrocher au pays de la loire ce
qui fait que votre façade est
hu était le péage de saint-arnoult dans
les yvelines ce qui évidemment pour les
habitants de l'île d'oléron dit libre et
pourrait poser une vraie difficulté et
une fille née nous avons obtenu ce que
nous souhaitions c'est à dire le
rapprochement à l'aquitaine avec
laquelle ils lui disent beaucoup lien
puisque bordeaux est notre capital
naturel économique politique médiatique
sportive mais le limousin et nous en
sommes ravis nous a rejoints dans la
nuit également sans que nous en ayons
été préalablement à forme
finalement ces régions très grande la
nouvelle équipe jeune c'est un peu le
sait la superficie du danemark ou de
l'autriche la population de settat moyen
européen
ces grandes régions parfois trop grande
ont permis au département de s'affirmer
et finalement de se rapprocher entre eux
nous avons mis en place comme dans la
plupart des régions des réunions
tous les deux ou trois mois des
présidents département même chose pour
nos directeurs généraux des services
même chose pour un certain nombre de nos
vices présidents donc nous avons appris
à travailler ensemble
non pas contre la région mais pour avoir
des positions communes dans nos
discussions avec la région à l'époque
dans les travaux de la commission des
lois c'est olivier du socle actuel
ministre qui est le rapporteur du texte
j'avais fondé beaucoup d'espoirs à
l'assemblée nationale sur la cpap je
suis bien obligé de reconnaître
malheureusement que ses espoirs étaient
infondées cc pap sont beaucoup trop
nombreux ici à toutes les
intercommunalités au bout d'une ou deux
réunions finalement plus personne ne
vient
et donc c'était ap qui aurait pu être
joué un rôle de coordination ont
malheureusement perdu en contrepartie ce
euros enfin pour terminer sur le début
de cette aventure la loi engagement de
proximité donc la loi du 29 décembre
2010 mais 19 a finalement très peu
modifié les choses peut-être certaines
délégations de compétence entre les
régions les départements tels étaient le
duo mais tous les amendements de bon
sens du sénat n'ont pas été acceptées à
ce moment là par le gouvernement nous
semble que dans cette période et le
travail mené par jean marie bockel et la
dcl et là votre délégation collectivités
territoriales le sondage que sa
délégation à commander qui a été
largement publiés montrent bien que les
départements ont accru leur place et je
vous incite à lire c'est publié ce matin
dans les échos et dans le b q les
extraits du rapport de l'institut
montaigne sur la gestion des
collectivités locales et la gestion de
la crise par l'état qui est également
très intéressant et qui conforte un peu
ce que nous pensons nous avons eu un
moment une difficulté avec une métropole
vous en souvenez certaines métropoles
voulait absorber les départements et
finalement les unes après les autres en
partant de lille et en terminant par
nice ont finalement décroché
et ils ne sont pas partis dans cette
aventure je pense que nous pouvons tirer
des conclusions pour l'avenir
nous pouvons tirer les conclusions qui
revient dont je ne veux pas être trop
long aux meilleurs subsidiarité nous
pouvons tirer des conclusions de la
crise sanitaire en particulier les
nouvelles attributions que les
départements pourraient avoir en matière
médico social en matière sanitaire et
pour l'information votre information
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
travaillant actuellement avec
l'association des maires de france et
régions de france pour présenter dans le
cadre du secteur de la santé un certain
nombre de positions communes ou semble
d'ailleurs arrivé d'ores et déjà nous
sommes entrain simplement de les écrire
de manière la plus claire possible
nous voyons bien par exemple que la
double gestion et pad ars a été mauvaise
dans cette période comme d'ailleurs la
double gestion à erez préfet et qu'il
faut revoir complètement le système de
fonctionnement des ars aussi bien pour
la place des autres services de l'état
que pour la place des collectivités
voilà sinon nous avons toute une série
de mesures a proposé dans le cas d'un
nouveau texte de décentralisation nous
espérons que le gouvernement ira plus
loin que ce qui se préparait dans le cas
du texte 3d qui nous semblait assez peu
lassé peu efficient en tout cas c'est
peu novateur et donc nous préparons en
liaison avec le sénat puisque le
président du sénat votre commission des
lois d'autres délégations collectivités
territoriales travail sur sa tombe de
propositions donc nous aurons l'occasion
maires de france région france et
départements de france 2 présentée dans
la première quinzaine de juillet en lien
avec le travail du scénar des
propositions très fort pour une nouvelle
décentralisation tenant compte des
inconvénients de l'actuelle tels que
j'essayais voulait résumer en quelques
mots voilà je ne veux pas être plus
longs monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les essais ladder chers
collègues sur cette première
intervention massive ou résidents
le cas est ce que vous criez peut-être
d'abord bonjour bonjour à tous très
brièvement donc philippe pichery
on se connaît peu ou pas je suis
président du département no que depuis
moins de trois ans j'ai succédé à votre
collègue sénateur philippe adnot
je suis sens sans étiquette et je suis
très bien dans le l'adf ou avec mes
collègues nous partageons beaucoup de
deux visions communes
moi j'ai beaucoup d'enseignements par
rapport à cette période et je pense que
c'est dans le dans le débat que je vous
apporterai peut-être quelques éclairages
ait quelques quelques questionnements
mais j'ajouterai rien bien sûr aux
préliminaires à ce propos introductifs
du président de l'isro vous faire quand
ils ne nous rejoindra bien des gens que
je suis arrivé le catcheur non non je
viens de vous rejoindre ce gt dans une
visite d'un collège avec madame la
rectrice et je suis en voiture sur un
parking mais prêts à partager
effectivement l'expérience nous avons pu
vivre et de rebondir aussi sur les
questions que vous allez nous de poser
[Musique]
et ça peut varier les positions qu'elle
s'arrêterait au même département
on partage sortir avant nbc pour les
conditions et on attendait beaucoup nina
dans le vent sur la ville idée justement
jusqu'à leur antre nasale et avait dit
le financeur du corps social alors en
proposent les joies et les alliances
fluide soient dûment il faudra c'est la
défiance nous avons diesel en ligne les
mamans qui est dans la majorité dans les
garages et elhorga l'indépendance il y
est moins profitable à grigy ou des neuf
points il faudra en tout cas se
positionner ralliement en masse les 10
secondes en lousiane de sept mois et que
ce soit au niveau bbc comme au niveau
des structures jeu l'édition 2011 et les
menaçant
je peux répondre nos communes emploi
[Musique]
intéressant compromis le monde que sur 7
des politiques sociales et
médico-sociales donc ça fait l'objet
elle répète de travail en commun
d'harmonisation actuellement avec les
assemblées
l'association des maires de france et
les régions grosso modo sans uniformité
mais nous comprenons bien également le
fait que nos concitoyens souhaiteront
que les politiques des départements
soient les plus harmonisées possibles
nous demandons la conception la
définition des politiques sociales et
médico-sociales un chef de file à pour
limiter l'influencé des ars ou en tout
cas à participer mieux à la gouvernance
des rsg tout simplement vous raconter à
une anecdote j'ai appris dans mon
département la semaine dernière par la
presse qu'il y avait eu seize morts dans
un ehpad de mon département sans que le
maire de la commune le département le
préfet et l'ensemble des autorités en
étaient informés sont dits situation
naturellement tout à fait inacceptable
et je les ai dénoncé publiquement
donc nous souhaitons dans le cadre de
cette nouvelle décentralisation c'est
aux siens à travail qu'a fait votre
ancien collègue jean léonce dupont pour
le compte de l'adf avec frédéric bierry
le président du bas rhin est la création
d' agence départementale de solidarité
la gestion exclusive des maisons de
l'autonomie la mise en place d'une
tarification unique sociale et
médico-sociale la compétence pour
recruter nommer les directeurs d'ehpad
départementaux la gestion des bâtiments
des établissements sociaux
médico-sociaux la généralisation du
statut de la fonction publique
territoriale pour les personnes aux
établissements ainsi qu'un nouveau
service départemental de la protection
maternelle et infantile pour les enfants
3 600 j'ajoute
que nous voyons bien dans cette période
compliquée de rentrée scolaire ou de
rentrer dans les collèges ou les lycées
que le la médecine scolaire est en
grande déshérence et nous pensons que
les départements pourraient assurer la
compétence en matière de médecine
scolaire
donc voilà quelques-unes des pistes sur
lesquelles nous travaillons actuellement
et que nous allons concrétiser encore
plus publiquement dans les jours à venir
comment ce qu'elle oblige et une autre
contre emblématique enseigne jugla sénat
envisage une salle à manger pour
l'instant monsieur le sénateur nous
travaillons en parfaite harmonie avec
marie-anne montchamp mais ne seront
amenés sur ce point
à regarder les choses ensemble je ne
peux pas pour l'instant rentrait plus
dans le vif du sujet mais il n'y a pas
de compétition entre les scènes et ça et
les départements en tout cas dans la
réflexion que nous menons actuellement
la gélule grands noms du monde
les cocottes ans je tends les
enseignants en métropole rugby jonah
logements sans but dans le département
d'odienné et c'était pas choix des
moyens géant ce qui dilue et quel genre
si oui pour répondre à cette question il
ya eu en effet un moment une tentation
des métropoles est d'absorber nos
compétences ce qui nous posait problème
c'est que on est allé trop loin dans
cette analyse personnelle à mes yeux
dans la définition des métropoles dont
en exemple de la région centre val de
loire on trouve tours et orléans
mais si le débat parlementaire va durer
plus longtemps on aurait trouvé amboise
châteauroux loches un certain nombre de
petites villes dans les métropoles
donc nous pensons ou que les métropoles
ont toute leur utilité sur le plan
économique mais que l'organisation
actuelle des pouvoirs est correct alors
après il ya des cas particuliers il ya
la coexistence au tour de lyon du
département du rhône sur un nouveau
périmètre de la métropole lyonnaise qui
a les compétences d'un département la
métropole lyonnaise fait d'ailleurs
partie de l'adf il y avait le cas
particulier de paris qui était la fois
une ville et un département
on peut bien sûr améliorer les liens
entre métropole et et département pour
l'instant les seuls problèmes qui ont
existé se sont produits à dijon entre le
vôtre votre collègue
enfin entre le maire de dijon et le
président du département de côte-d'or
françois sauvadet
mais pour l'instant le débat métropole
n'a pas été réouvert par département et
par le gouvernement pardon et comme le
gouvernement l'a abordée tout le monde
s'étant retiré à pas contés départ tout
le monde est enthousiaste
lille s'est retirée puis ensuite nature
ensuite bordeaux puis ensuite marseille
puis ensuite nice puis ensuite toulouse
où les affrontements étaient assez assez
violent tout cas sur le plan vocal
je pense que le problème ne se pose plus
et qu'on attend vraiment des métropoles
leur rôle économique et le rôle
d'aménagement du territoire mais que
personne en réalité n'a eu envie de
prendre la compétence sociale quand les
métropoles ont vu ce qui manque au
département est ce qui va manquer encore
plus dans la crise actuelle payer le rsa
pour payer la pas pour les personnes
âgées pour payer la prestation de
compensation du handicap en regardant
les choses de plus près à grand nombre
de responsables des trop polis cas se
sont dit qu'il n'était pas finalement
spécialement demandeur de récupérer nos
compétences en matière de solidarité
sociale
et quant à la solidarité territoriale on
voit bien que si dans des territoires
qui entoure les grandes métropoles et
pas le département avec les
intercommunalités pour assurer une
solidarité territoriale ça peut être
mortifère pour les plus petites communes
donc ce débat a eu lieu il a été tranché
par le chef de l'état par le
gouvernement pour l'instant il n'est pas
réouvert mais naturellement puisque les
nouvelles autorités métropolitaine vont
très très lues au mois de juillet sans
dans l'ensemble des territoires
peut-être que certains nouveaux patrons
de métropole ou leur exécutif auront
envie de le réouvrir et nous serons
évidemment très attentifs à au maintien
de la situation actuelle non pas par
conservatisme mais parce que nous
pensons qu'il ya une différenciation des
rôles il nous paraît plutôt saine
dans l'état actuel des choses
merci à frans je suis vraiment
sincèrement désolé pour le retard je
vais vous dire que le parti de retard
quitte à mon âge il est lié à ce que
vous venez d'évoquer à la fable de nef
qui est assez mal la métropole le
département la région
je vais le dire à ses fans le
département avec les métropoles là elle
existe là où elle ne s'est justement à
80 et disent que je suis un curé plus
longtemps à la coop venir effectivement
sur l'éthique de l'action +23 question
de la lumière semble banal ce sens est
ce que vous observez aujourd'hui quelque
5 ans après la fusion de certaines
régions mais il a des relations
différentes entre les exécutifs
départementaux les exécutifs régionaux
se lance nous noterons très grandes
régions dites fusionner et d'autres
régions sont restés dans leur périmètre
oui ça c'est la version la génération
qui dès les poules c est ce que ces
relations et partenaires en région qui
ont qui ont évolué son miel certainement
des clarifications de compétences de
réfléchir pour pétanque
je voudrais pas messi en est déjà à
l'époque j'étais dans ma ville
finalement les relations par contre
difficile soit confiée en conséquence
d'une
d'organisation des compétences des
départements et régions
est ce que ces difficultés parce que ces
gens quittent cette source de la
politique ici se retrouvent
indépendamment de couleur politique plus
ou moins sa cime hier soir les figures
évoqué une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai déjà proposé beaucoup qui quand
même la crise tout le monde parle pour
lui
besoin notre regard du sel immédiat aux
balises et d'initiatives solidaires et
des françaises et des français
elle c'est au centre d'ailleurs c'est
pas si la loi en détenir nous appartient
pas en tant qu ils nous défient la
solidarité mais quelle est la place que
les départements peu
dois je vais faire certaines mort de ma
voix vous évoquez sociale la camisole
mais que personne ne se bat cette beauté
pansard et d'une solidarité territoriale
pour le coup il ya peut-être un peu plus
de jeu de poudre entre parfois dans un
effectif métropolitain grand super six
et des exécutifs régionaux des
départements qui pensent à autre un
petit peu plus ou mytho sur cette somme
1 répondant la ficelle vivez vous à
l'aune des dames les deux dernières un
élève ou réciter le monde et gilet jaune
démontre que nous aurons besoin dans une
république décente et de travail et je
leur souhaite
je souhaite que philippe pichet leur en
somme on puisse s'exprimer après moi
parce qu'ils ont leur expérience qui
n'est pas la même et le regard qui peut
être différent dans les autres pensées
dans le
la fameuse région grand est région
département pendant cette période de
crise il ya eu beaucoup de choses faites
ensemble en particulier savez dans
beaucoup de régions les commandes de
masques de blues 2 / blues de matériels
divers ont fait l'objet de commandes
comme une des régions les départements
il ya eu également un travail en commun
sur la relance économique par l'exemple
d'un nouvel acquis qu'à nous étions deux
fois par semaine
en audio en visioconférence les 12
départements et le président notre
région et les aspects d'étiquette
politique que je jouais très peu dans
les prises de position des uns et des
autres je dirais même pas du tout
simplement si vous voulez je pense que
c'est certainement plus facile lorsque
le périmètre historique est respectée
lorsque la région et est de taille
convenable que dans les grandes régions
où il faut parfois des centaines de
kilomètres pour une moindre réunion est
d'ailleurs cette période va certainement
permettre de développer le travail en
audio en visio et d'éviter les
kilomètres que parcouraient nos
collègues conseillers régionaux
auparavant ont parfois des très peu de
temps au siège de la région
le périmètre les couleurs politiques
jouent peut dire est qu'il ya eu
évidemment des présidents de région qui
peuvent avoir des grandes ambitions
nationales et s'ils en ont c'est qu'ils
en ont les moyens intellectuels et
politiques et donc on a pu voir dans
certaines régions des présidents de
région s'occuper vouloir s'occuper des
services départementaux d'incendié et de
secours
voir s'occuper des collèges enfin il ya
eu parfois des choses assez amusante que
les observateurs et la presse qu et nous
mêmes et vous en tant qu'observatrice
faire de la vie politique et acteurs
avaient certainement noté ça s'est un
peu les des personnes ya eu des guerres
d'ego c'est à qui remettait hamas mais
devant la devant les caméras ou devant
les photographes de la presse
quotidienne régionale
bon tout ça je dirais tu mens et sans
gravité à partir du moment ça n'entraîne
pas des dysfonctionnements
dont souffriraient nos concitoyens et
plus sérieusement madame la rapporteur
sur les transferts de compétences je
crois qu'il ya deux domaines où les
choses aux encore des difficultés
le transport scolaire je pense que
donner l'entière compétences du
transport scolaire et du transport
routier aux régions restent des choses
qu'il n'a pas toujours donné de bons
résultats parce que souvent avec une
ligne de transport scolaire nous
faisions des lignes d'aménagement du
territoire
les ondées desserte fine que les régions
n'ont pas toujours maintenu pour des
raisons financières
donc pas mal de présidents de
départements estime qu'en matière de
transport scolaire ou en matière de
transport routier de voyageurs
la performance est moins bonne que celle
du passé chacun peut y avoir là dessus
des appréciations
selon sa situation géographique et enfin
plus plus gravement l'économie
on voit bien que dans dispositif de
l'état et dieu sait qu'il est puissant
dans les dispositifs des régions et dieu
sait qu'ils sont puissants
il ya des trous dans la raquette ce qui
amène un certain nombre de départements
à contourner la loi notre malgré une
circulaire un petit peu on jugé assez
déplacé en pleine crise de notre amie
jacqueline gourault début mai ce qui a
amené un certain nombre de départements
à prendre des initiatives en matière
économique sont pas mal de onenote en
des exemples département de l'orne qui
rajoute aux 15 100 euros de l'état 500
euros ou d'autres départements qui
rajoute au dispositif de la région
d'autres qui font des avances économique
d'autres qui font des avances aux
interco pour leurs politiques
économiques
jusqu'à présent la vendait à prendre une
pente est d'exemple jusqu'à présent à
part marseille c'est un cas toujours un
peu particulier sur le plan politique
les préfets ont laissé faire
à partir du moment ces dispositifs
n'était pas comment dire
claironner ou n'étaient pas de nature à
remettre complètement en cause l'esprit
de la loi nôtre est donc pour l'instant
ces dispositifs se déploie avec une
grande discrétion
mais avec une certaine efficacité et ça
montre bien que la loi d'autres est allé
trop loin en enlevant toute compétence
économique au département certaines nos
collègues d'ailleurs de différentes
obédiences politiques en profitent je
les comprends pour redemander le retour
à la compétence générale ont fait un
dernier mot avant de passer la parole
madame la rapporteure du président si
vous voulez bien à philippe pichery
alors en saumon pour dire que nous nous
sentons bien dans notre job de
solidarité la solidarité sociale et on
pense après cette crise qu'on est encore
allé beaucoup plus loin dans le
développement de notre rôle et les
solidarités territoriales on voit bien
que pendant cette période
allez petite commune avait besoin de
nous c'est nous qui les avons
provisionné en bas c'est vous qui les
avons aidés à réouvrir leur école c'est
nous qui leur avons apporté beaucoup de
prestations donc je pense que les
régions toute leur légitimité pour avoir
encore plus de compétences en matière
d'économie en matière d'emploi je pense
qu'elle devrait avoir beaucoup plus de
compétences de l'est
les politiques de l'emploi dans la mise
au point avec nous des contrats de plan
état région associant les autres
collectivités que les départements nous
pouvons fortifier notre rôle social et
territorial et que quand les gens sont
raisonnables c'est le cas dans 99% des
cas le couple au département
intercommunalité commune fonctionne bien
et j'espère qu'après la fin des
élections municipales et la mise en
place des instances en juillet ces
couples pourront continuer à fonctionner
de manière harmonieuse
no mercy des mouvements bien écouter
effectivement moi j'ai la particularité
d'avoir connu la région donc champagne
ardenne quand j'étais directeur général
des services de cette collectivité est
aujourd'hui de connaître la région grand
est
je note des différences des différences
fondamentales alors je tiens tout de
suite à dire que c'est pas une question
politique et c'est pas une question
d'hommes
hommes s'entendent s'apprécie on
vraiment la volonté de travailler
ensemble et d'ailleurs à l'époque le
département de l'aube était
politiquement différents de la région
champagne ardenne alors qu'aujourd'hui
au contraire il ya une harmonie avec la
l'art et la région grand est
mais il est incontestable que ces
grandes régions par la part la distance
ont induit un une réalité qui fait que
nous finalement j'ai un peu le sentiment
qu'on vit sa vie un peu chacun de son
côté et qui à bien des sujets sur
lesquels on aurait matière à échanger à
avancer ensemble
mais la distance a rompu ce ce lien de
collaboration
aujourd'hui s'il faut aller depuis trois
strasbourg il ya il ya quatre heures et
demie de route il faut prendre la
journée si c'est plus avant pour aller
de 2,3 châlons en champagne
on pouvait même sur une demi-journée
même mois pouvoir se rencontrer avant
c'est donc il ya indiscutablement par la
dimension compris les choses
un éloignement qui pour moi est
préjudiciable à l'action au collectif je
reviens sur l'exemple qu'à utiliser le
président busserolles et les transports
scolaires ont je crois que ça a souvent
été dit c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une aberration que d'avoir retiré au
département les transports scolaires ce
étroitement liées à la gestion de nos
routes étroites mans liés à la gestion
de nos établissements avec lesquels on
est en contact quotidien
et puis on a gardé le transport des
handicapés et aujourd'hui il ya des
surcoûts parce que chacun organise mais
il faut qu'on essaye de se concerter le
transport qui lui incombe alors que le
transport handicapés dans une démarche
d'inclusion et de deux places du
handicapées dans la société avait été
organisée dans un certain nombre de
situations pour ce faire dans le même
transports
que les élèves non handicapés je crois
qu'une moi ce que j'ai noté depuis des
années c'est que les régions étaient
face à un challenge absolument
considérable ça a été d'abord la mienne
est composé de trois anciennes régions
il a fallu harmoniser des anciennes
politiques pour définir un cadre commun
et ça ça a été très long et je crois
surtout que le problème que ça pose on a
parlé de solidarité
le problème que ça pose c'est que on
peut pas prendre en compte les
spécificités les atouts des handicaps
qui peut y avoir sur certains
territoires à l'intérieur de la région
et donc pendant pendant très longtemps
effectivement et c'est un travail
considérable la région a dû définir ces
nouvelles politiques et j'ai grand
plaisir au cours d'un dernier entretien
avec le président de région jean rottner
en terme a dit maintenant on va
travailler au plus près des territoires
et on va plus travailler avec avec une
politique uniforme sur tout le
territoire régional
mais on va travailler avec des contrats
de territoire et voir ce qui est le plus
important sur chaque territoire et donc
j'espère que cette cette phase va va
renforcer nos liens qui sont solides
mais qui ont pu laisser des frustrations
parce qu'effectivement la distance cette
harmonisation des politiques a pris a
pris beaucoup de temps
on a parlé de solidarité la solidarité
non qu'on est bien au niveau des
départements
la solidarité c'est de faire plus pour
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
on parle souvent de discrimination
positive
la solidarité c'est de mettre en oeuvre
des discriminations positives c'est vrai
qu'au niveau des régions des grandes
régions qui ont qui sont composés de
plusieurs régions ça a été pendant un
temps très difficile de s'engager dans
cette voie il y avait il y avait
d'autres priorités
je voudrais évoquer le domaine de
l'économie qu'à et doké
le président du sro j'y suis tout
particulièrement sensible philippe adnot
mon prédécesseur avait fait de
l'économie le fer de lance est de
l'enseignement supérieur le fer de lance
du développement du département
ce département il consacré des sommes
très importantes et la loi notre et la
disparition de la clause de compétence
générale et surtout de la compétence
économique a été pour la collectivité un
vrai traumatisme
alors nous avons pu nous organiser pour
transférer les moyens conséquents dont
nous disposions pour agir dans
l'économie vers les opci mais souvent
avec beaucoup de difficultés qui avait
cette connaissance mais aujourd'hui il
ya des ja 10 trous importants qui reste
dans la raquette comme l'a dit dominique
je vais vous citer deux exemples le
département a créé de l'aube à créer une
université développer une technopole un
hôtel d'entreprises pépinière
d'entreprises tout un cluster qui a qui
a profondément modifié l'économie du
département
aujourd'hui cette superbe organisation
et machines tournent au ralenti
elle tourne au ralenti parce que le
relais n'a pas pu être pris ni par le
pci locale qui n'en a pas les moyens ni
par la région qui a dû harmoniser une
politique homogène sur son territoire et
aujourd'hui il y aurait besoin de
construire de nouveaux bâtiments
devant cette techno pôle pour accueillir
les startups les créateurs d'entreprise
qui frappe à la porte et qui sont là et
qui veulent venir
et ces entreprises elles étaient
accueillies dans des bâtiments
construits par le département
aujourd'hui le département de l'aube a
toujours des moyens significatifs et
voudrait construire ces bâtiments
il ne le peut pas et la loi ne le permet
pas on a bien passé les conventions avec
le pci pour par convention apporter des
aides à l'immobilier
lee et d'entreprises mais ce sont des
aides par rapport à l'immobilier mais il
n'y a pas la possibilité dans la loi
actuelle de conventionner pour confier à
un autre acteur la construction
immobilière et donc on est on est bloqué
c'est dramatique parce que il y avait
une superbe dynamique qui s'est arrêtée
ce sont des centaines d'emplois je le
dis avec beaucoup de conviction ce sont
des centaines d'emplois qui devait être
créé et qui ne sont pas créés et autres
cas on a des opci qui ont qui sont de
petite taille qui ont peu de moyens on a
eu un cas où une belle entreprise venait
s'installer dans le cadre de
l'installation
il fallait une garantie qui
correspondait pour le pci un montant qui
n'était pas compatible avec ces moyens
qui pour le département était une
garantie tout à fait facile à apporter
avec le département pouvait apporter la
loi d'aujourd'hui ne le permet pas nous
ce que moi ce que je pense et ce que je
vis c'est qu'il nous faut trouver des
souplesses comme l'a dit dominique
bussereau je crois que ce sera pas le
grand soir du retour de la clan de la
clause de compétence générale
même si ça aurait du sens mais j'ai
l'habitude de dire que c'est devenu un
sujet tabou
donc essayons essayons d'être efficace
mais il faut je crois trouver le chemin
pour qu'effectivement en matière
d'intervention économique de proximité
les départements comme celui de l'eau
qui ont les moyens qu'ils ont les
compétences et puisse puisse avancer
je vais vous dire pour terminer une
chose que tout le monde sait ici dans
l'eau le département de l'aude n'a plus
la compétence économique
et pourtant c'est est de très très loin
aujourd'hui encore un acteur majeur du
développement économique local pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'il est
toujours propriétaire de tous les
terrains de zone
industriels sur lesquels les entreprises
nouvelles secret et qu'il est toujours
propriétaire d'un patrimoine immobilier
très conséquent qu'il met à disposition
de ses entreprises
pour la petite histoire à l'origine sur
les locations de ce patrimoine
les services de l'état la préfète de
région avaient attaqué une délibération
leurs délibérations du département au
tribunal administratif
le tribunal administratif a débouté
l'état en disant qu' il n'y avait pas de
d'investissements nouveaux c'était de la
gestion patrimoine en bon père de
famille et on est dans cette situation
aujourd'hui le départ toutes les
implantations nouvelles qui se font de
ce fonds que grâce à l'action passée du
département mais le relais n'a pas été
pris et moi je pense que il faut
sereinement en lien avec les communes en
lien avec les opci en lien avec les
régions que l'on trouve les voies pour
un atout un assouplissement nos
territoires sont différents ils ont des
caractéristiques différents nous ne
réussirons dans la mission qui est la
nôtre que si on arrive à intégrer et à
prendre en compte ces spécificités nous
pensons 20 ans contre nous et nous ne
sommes ni madame madame là à porter
bonjour mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
mes chers collègues juste quelques mots
dire tout à fait je partage complètement
ce qu'a dit dominique bussereau par
rapport effectivement aux relations
département région quoiqu'il y ait de
grandes différences en fonction
effectivement des régions soit qu'elles
ont été fusionnés ou pas fusionner entre
différentes régions précédente dire que
chez nous par exemple dans les hauts de
france ça a été tout d'abord un débat où
il ya eu la volonté sûrement de des
régions des traces et hégémonique je
vais dire m'entends très bien avec
xavier bertrand mais le plus tôt une
certaine hégémonie au départ qui était
souhaité dans la mise en place des
nouvelles régions et puis les choses se
sont stabilisées on a bien vu que la
volonté de proximité des régions étaient
compliquées adopté compte tenu de ce qui
vient dire philippe pichery sur la
géographie des nouvelles régions
et qui se sont donc plus appuyé sur les
départements compte tenu de leur
historique de leur histoire et notamment
de leurs capacités en termes de
proximité deuxième fois je dois dire
c'est que en matière de chef de file a
encore faudrait-il que l'on n'applique
le chef de file a dans tous les domaines
et que l'on reconnaisse véritablement
comme l'a dit le président bussereau ce
qu'est le chef de file 1 si le chef de
file à des solidarités sociales
c'est le département et bien il doit
être le chef de file et doit décider
bien sûr avec le respect des lois que
décide le gouvernement de pouvoir être
le maître du jeu si je puis dire sur son
territoire départemental ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas plus qu'il y a et ça
a été dit notamment dans le cadre des
métropoles ya pas forcément la volonté
des métropoles de vouloir prendre tout
tout le côté social de la solidarité
sociale pour autant il ya des des
escarmouches en tout cas des volontés
ici ou là
pas forcément des métropoles mais
parfois de com d'agglo sont des huiles
en particulier chez moi qui a des
velléités au travers leur ccas 2 vouloir
reprendre un peu de mal sur un certain
nombre de politiques sociales qui sont
pourtant delà de la compétence jaillir
pas su régalienne du conseil
départemental
donc il ya vraiment une nécessité a
reprécisé ce qu'est le chef de file a à
ce point de vue d'ailleurs comme le
disait le président bussereau le chef de
file en matière économique est bien
reconnue à la région et donc on voit
bien qu'il a décidé sur un certain
nombre de proches pour les hôtes france
de solliciter les départements sur des
compétences qui ne sont pas les ciels et
pour lequel l'état n'a pas eu à revenir
jouer en cité emblématique c'est la
réalisation du canal seine nord europe
c'est des transports et ce fameux canal
seine nord europe dont on parle depuis
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années
enfin trouver une conclusion sous
réserve que les départements qui n'ont
pourtant pas la compétence transport et
bien viennent mettre la main à la poche
et viennent financer ce projet c'est
donc bien la preuve que cette je ne veux
pas non plus revenir sur la clause de
compétence générale je pense que ce
n'est pas forcément un débat il faut
remettre sur la table
effectivement ça sera pas le grand soir
mais pour autant je pense que sans
revenir totalement sur la loi nome
il ya une nécessité que la loi notre
s'adapte aux territoires on ne demande
pas à rebattre toutes les cartes mais
quand fonction effectivement et on a pu
vivre avec cette crise du comique 19
qu'il faut avoir des relations très
privilégiées que les chefs de file
depuis
orienter les politiques associer les
partenaires en fonction des orientations
des priorités que le chef de file donne
en l'occurrence dans le cadre de
l'économie des hauts de france sous la
houlette de xavier bertrand ont décidé
de prendre une délibération générale qui
permet à toute collectivité de pouvoir
abondé et qu'il n'offrira aucune
restriction considérant que ça venait en
soutien des entreprises des activités
qui est en difficulté
là où le bât blesse je dirais que c'est
en l'occurrence dans la discussion qu'on
peut avoir entre départements et régions
pour celle que je vis au quotidien s'est
laissé happer les conférences
territoriales de l'action publique sur
les compétences partagées en tout cas
chez nous nous sont aujourd'hui pas
défini et quand on nous dit alors on est
en responsabilité de compétences
partagées tels le tourisme l'agriculture
le sport de ne pas pouvoir aider
notamment attendre économique et toute
l'hôtellerie la restauration en
particulier restauration et on ne
pourrait pas intervenir parce que on n'a
pas la compétence économique
ça paraît un petit peu désuet et surtout
et surtout ça va naturellement beaucoup
pénalisé les entreprises qui sont
affectés
d'autre part je ne sais pas quel est le
cas dans d'autres régions mais pour ceux
qui y étaient de la fusion dans les
hauts de france
les deux régions nord pas de calais et
les régions picardie avait deux
traitements différents dans les
contractualisations décès per est un
région il y avait dans le nord pas de
calais une contractualisation auquel les
départements étaient associés et en
picardie où il n'y avait pas de
contractualisation ou les départements
est associé mais un contrat entre chaque
département et la région de picardie
ce qui avait le mérite peut-être pas le
meilleur dans tous les cas de permettre
d'avoir une relation très privilégiée
entre régions et départements pour se
fixer des objectifs sur des
investissements qui étaient des
priorités départementales qui était
soutenu par la région
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
sera dans tous les cas il ya une
certaine incertitude en tout cas dans
les hauts de france pour savoir comment
ces futurs cp verts seront seront fixés
ont je crois qu'il ya encore une fois
pas forcément à tous on veut tour balayé
yahia a donné à cette web nokia un
corset trop monolithique plus de
souplesse pour pouvoir s'adapter qui en
fonction de son économie en fonction de
son environnement
pas d éviter que donne à la fois les
riches fils est à la fois pour les
départements là où sont eux mêmes chefs
de file j'avais j'avais terminé je ne
sais pas si vous avez tout entendu mais
en tout cas elle avait terminé à noël
mais le premier league où je vais vous
en maintenant une somme de droit qu'il
surnomme d'année connaît qui sont avec
nous
numérique pour nous et simplement leur
idole lui les nommer j merci président
merci au président plus trop une
première remarque pour rebondir sur les
propos précédents sur les ars les crs
qui n'ont pas beaucoup sollicité les
labos départementaux dans le cas de la
crise sanitaire qui montre collaboration
en l'absence de collaboration
indispensable
ensuite sur un plan plus gobelins global
les élus locaux sont souvent de monteur
de plus de décentralisation selon son
président pour ne parler que compétences
obligatoires
est ce que certains pontes sociale les
conseils départementaux n'ont pas la
main sur tout je pense notamment la
gestion du rsa ne devrait pas revenir à
l'état et puis autre question les cdo
enfin les conseils départementaux un
rôle de proximité des partenariats
anciens avec les communes et les opci et
en matière de lisibilité et d'efficacité
ne serait-il pas plus opportun au moins
dans les territoires ruraux de
conventionner avec les ep six sont la
compétence échos plutôt que d'assister
sur les partenariats avec les régions
qui tire la couverture souvent sur un
regard bienveillant des préfets de
région en contournant la loi nous tous
merci merci
ces questions frère merci au caire des
gilets sénateur de la gironde messieurs
les présidents madame le rapporteur
j'écoutais beaucoup d'attention les
différentes interventions et d agir ou
d'un loup poser la question suivante
vous avez évoqué les uns et les autres
la question de subsidiarité
en fait cette question elle est
insuffisamment au fond dit puisque si
nous les mettions en oeuvre réellement
dans ce qu'elle peut être dans cette
définition complète on pourrait
s'appuyer et lumière très forte sur les
subsides ya été pour mettre en place des
politiques d'action avec des transferts
de compétences
ces transferts de compétences ils
peuvent s'interroger à partir du moment
où celui qui est porteur de la
compétence accepte de la déléguée on
peut déléguer à ce qu'on a une
compétence dans une relation de
subsidiarité
donc ça c'est une notion qui mériterait
d'être travaillé pour créer des
nouvelles agilité des nouvelles
souplesse sur les politiques sur les
politiques d'intervention
enfin l'autre sujet c'est la question
des contrats de coopération
ce sujet vient d'être évoquée à
l'occasion des discussions et des
négociations de contrats de plan état
région pour certains d'entre eux ils
soient sociales et départements pour
d'autres les préfets les ont parfois
quelque part ignorer mais il est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de régions ont pris
l'initiative de mettre en place ses
formes de contrats de coopération entre
la région et les départements qui la
composent
ça pourrait être une une orientation à
celle vertueuse en fait pour l'ensemble
des régions de pouvoir s'appuyer sur ces
contrats de coopération donc discuté
négocié et qui pour le coup pourrait
également affirmé cette notion aussi de
subsidiarité dans la mise en place
factuel et pratiques de certaines
politiques territoriales
qu'en pensez vous masi éléments oui
bonjour messieurs les présidents est ce
que vous entendez oui il semblerait
écoutez je suis sénateur du bas-rhin et
conseillers résume à de grands tests
j'avais lorsque j'ai demandé la parole
j'ai souhaité mais vous interrogeait
messieurs les présidents sur la
compétence économique mais ces questions
déjà été vues donc je vais vous poser
deux autres questions une concernant
l'aménagement du territoire et la
proximité et l'autre sur la coopération
transfrontalière
d'abord sur l'aménagement du territoire
moi je suis de ceux qui bien qu'étant du
même bord politique que jean rottner a
voté contre le sras dette schéma
régional d'aménagement du territoire
tout simplement parce que non pas bien
sûr pour des raisons politiques mais
tout simplement parce que je considérais
que ce sera dette dont vous connaissez
naturellement les conséquences
importantes sur les territoires infra
n'était pas assez territorialisée sur
des notamment des domaines très
importants pour les collectivités
locales de consommation frontières et
autres on mettait tout le monde sous la
même toise et circulez ya rien à voir
malgré les demandes des départements
malgré les départs les demandes et scott
et c'est ne pas voulu changer
j'ai été jusqu'à voter contre qu'est ce
que vous pensez messieurs les présidents
de de l'intérêt de ce sera d'être dans
des grandes régions
je connaisse c'est le grand est ça me
ramène à la proximité qu'est ce que vous
pensez du fait que une région donc la
mienne le grand test se soit doté de
tous mais dans douze maisons de la
région en plus les trois anciens hôtels
de région je veux même pas parler de de
l'appartement qui a été acheté à paris
boulevard saint germain mais c'est une
autre affaire qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la duplication de de cette proximité
des maisons de la région ailleurs que
dans les départements plus dans les
hôtels département c'est même pas
rapprocher les département à cet égard
ont créé ces maisons et enfin dernière
question la coopération transfrontalière
on veut faire de la coopération
transfrontalière au niveau grand-est moi
ce que je sais
pour l'avoir pratiqué par le passé
lorsque un moment j'ai des présidents de
région alsace et avant vice président en
charge du développement économique c'est
que la coopération transfontalière ça
fonctionne à travers des relations
personnelles humaine est désolé de le
dire
la coopération transfrontalière avec le
pays de bade juste à côté de chez moi
obéit à l'aider les concepts personnel
on connaît le ministre des transports
juste de l'autre côté du rhin ne paye
pas d' on arrive à quelque chose bien je
suis moins persuadé qu'on ne peut pas
régler les problèmes de coopération
transfontalière de la même façon avec et
le luxembourg est naturellement le
palatinat et la sarre et le pays
vraiment moi je milite pour ça va vous
faire plaisir messieurs une
territorialisation une voire une départ
allez une taie rituel dire comme sa
territorialisation départementale dans
les régions des grandes régions
fusionner sinon ça n'a pas de sens et je
pense que nous allons très franchement
être sanctionnés aux prochaines
élections régionales en alsace et sur à
travers les les sondages d'ailleurs
d'après ce que dit un presse quotidienne
régionale il semblerait que les les
populations tant lorraine que
champardennaise ne sont pas plus
convaincu que les alsaciens par part
merci de vos réponses
merci les parties de questions mais ses
chances avec lui je vais je vais aller
très vite sur la série de questions pour
permettre à philippe piat laurent de
donner leur sentiment
eric gold a parlé des labos
départementaux c'est quelque chose
d'assez significatif on s'est battu
auprès d'olivier ferrand pour dire que
nos labos départementaux
interdépartementaux qui font du
vétérinaire de l'analyse des eaux des
repas cetera pouvait être utile et il a
fallu une longue bagarre pour que on les
met en service un arbitrage au plus haut
niveau de l'état pour que les labos
départementaux soit sociaux campagne de
dépistage
et après on a souvent vu les ars faire
en sorte de ne pas les utiliser ou pas
assez et parfois ils sont restés un
petit peu avec leurs armes leur équipe
sans pour intervenir sur le rsa c'est un
repas chez nous c'est pas un débat
droite gauche d'ailleurs il ya des
présidents de sensibilité de gauche de
droite qui sont favorables à la
recentralisation du rsa non pas des
politiques d'insertion à je parle de
l'aspect largement d'autres qu'ils ne
sont pas de toute façon nous avons dit
au gouvernement qu'il fallait ouvrir un
débat sur le rsa parce que comme nous
avons une montée en puissance très fort
des chiffres du rsa depuis le bas de
mars avril commençons à voir les
chiffres de mai qui ne sont pas bons
dans tous les départements
arias cirque le fait qu' on n'a pas les
mêmes méthodes de contrôle que
d'habitude il ya quelqu un aspect un peu
arithmétique mais il faut remettre sur
la table le problème du financement du
rsa quant aux conventions et rigole avec
les ep c'est plutôt qu'avec les régions
le problème pour l'ex connexes et
parfois les ep s'ils n'ont pas les
équipes c'est pareil d'ailleurs par
rapport à la loi de madame board sur les
mobilités
on dit aux jeux pc il fait du transport
local
s'ils n'ont pas les équipes parce que la
région nouvel acquis tels qu'on connaît
bien à l'origine et mois valait
s'occuper de louper un petit système de
transport a fait le thym dans la creuse
pour une communauté de communes qui n'a
pas de prix mais la technique dont
souvent le problème avec les pc pour
l'action économique c'est que les
petites pci ceux qui ont été regroupés
par la voix préfectoral n'ont parfois
pas les moyens d'agir dans ces domaines
des transports comme dans les domaines
de l'action économique sur les questions
d'hervé gilet sur la subsidiarité
on peut en effet aller beaucoup plus
loin dans les délégations de compétence
dans la région à laquelle nous
appartenons lui et moi on a et les
conventions très clair pour la la forêt
l'agriculture la conchyliculture bien
d'autres domaines on peut aller plus
loin quand tous ces per lesoudier
département c'est d'être au tour de la
caf
j'ai la chance d'avoir mon album comme
préfet de région l'époque quand on a
fait le contrat de plus l'enquêté signée
par manuel valls
les départements et les communautés
d'agglo étaient autour de la table
ç'a permis d'avoir des financements très
préparée très élaborés et c'est mieux
de se tourner ensuite vers le
département une fois que les décisions
ont été prises au niveau régional sur
l'aménagement du territoire moi je suis
assez comment dire peu optimiste sur
l'estrade est fondée grand machin je
suis pas sûr de leur efficacité réelle
sur le terrain sur les maisons de région
je trouve mieux quand la maison de la
région se situe au siège du département
a souvent eu besoin des bergers des
services de la région pour les
transports on a essayé de le faire dans
des locaux déjà départementaux du tome
d'obliger les régions à créer leur
propre leurs propres implantations et
quand on la sent transfrontalière
patricia schillinger ou andré reichardt
le savent bien
c'est quand même dans le grand test les
relations avec le badge rotenberg avec
le luxembourg de patrick weiten de
brigitte klinkert de frédéric bierry mme
de telle ou telle qu'on faciliter les
opérations de transfert et de l'est
qu'ils nous ont apporté nos voisins
européens dans cette période c'est vrai
que plus la coopération transfrontalière
se fait de personne à personne avec des
gens qui ont l'habitude de travailler
entre eux qu'ils se connaissent qui
parlent les langues respectives de la et
de l'autre c'est parfois plus facile
qu'au niveau d'une très grande région
mais moi c'est différent ce que nouvelle
aquitaine nous n'avons qu'est ce pagne
tandis que vous avez dans le grand est
évidemment toute une série d'
interlocuteur très différents et des
pays également très différents merci
bien bien volontiers sur la sur la
première intervention alors d'abord ce
que je veux dire mais ça a été une des
grandes caractéristiques de cette
période de crise c'est que les modalités
de coopération ont pu être très
différente d'un territoire à un autre
selon les personnes en présence selon la
façon dont l oeuvre dont elles ont la
volonté d'oeuvrer ensemble
concernant la rs le laboratoire
départemental
de l'homme lui a fait un travail très
intéressant avec la rs sont ces mêmes
équipés d'installations complémentaires
et aujourd'hui effectivement notre
laboratoire est un pilier dans la
réalisation des analyses par rapport aux
prélèvements sur sur la proximité et le
conventionnement avec les opci alors il
me semble que la question se pose un peu
différemment
pour ma part j'ai conventionné à la fois
avec des opci avec trois champagnes
métropole pour continuer à apporter des
aides à l'immobilier d'entreprise des
bonifications de loyers sur les
entreprises accueillies sur la
technopole de l'eau et j'ai
conventionnés avec la région sur un
fonds complémentaire avec l'état le
fonds résistance dans le cadre
effectivement delà de la situation qu'au
vide
en fait me semble-t-il dès lors que les
gens s'entendent
on peut avoir des conventions c'est vrai
que celle de proximité avec le
territoire les opci avec lesquels on a
un rapport très étroit sont peut-être un
petit peu plus simple en gestion mais je
crois avant tout que le conventionnement
d'abord il est dicté par le cadre de la
loi en matière économique
les opci ont la compétence de
l'immobilier d'entreprise et les régions
ont la compétence des aides aux
entreprises en dehors de l'immobilier
donc ils sont sûrs d'eux sauf erreur de
ma part
ils sont sur deux segments différents et
selon l'objectif que l'on a on
conventionnés avec l'un ou avec l'autre
le vrai problème et je l'évoqué il ya un
instant c'est que dans ce dispositif de
conventionnement tel qu'il est prévu par
la loi
il ya des manques et notamment dans le
conventionnement avec les opci il n'est
pas possible de conventionner pour que
le département construit un bâtiment
pour accueillir une entreprise ou pour
il développe et des des activités
d'accueil d'entreprises de haute
technologie est des deux start sur sur
la subsidiarité effectivement moi je
crois beaucoup à cette subsidiarité et
j'ai souvent eu des discussions que ce
soit avec jean rottner pour la région
avec françois baroin pour la la
métropole de 2,3 sur des choses qui
pourraient nous être déléguées au
département dans la mesure où on a
quelques compétences et moyens mais il
ya des domaines que la loi ne permet pas
de délai est donc pour rebondir sur la
sur la question je crois que
effectivement des cours des contrats de
coopération
ça me semble être tout à fait dans
l'esprit de travail en commun de new
différents niveaux de collectivités
ça me semble être vraiment la bonne idée
pour tenir compte des spécificités de
chaque territoire
mais encore faut-il que la loi le
permettent
parce que dominique bussereau l'a évoqué
je crois que la situation actuelle dans
la crise où effectivement on a bien
senti que l'autorité d'état fait preuve
d'une grande clémence par rapport à un
certain nombre de décisions elle ne
poursuit pas sur le fondement de la
seule légalité parce que c'est l'intérêt
de tous
mais c'est quand même une situation qui
est pas satisfaisant je crois qu'il ya
quand même derrière cette situation et
il ya quand même un risque que court nos
collectivités
parce que si un seul administrés lui
venait à contester ce type de 10
libération qui il régale cause et puis
j'en profite aussi pour dire je n'ai pas
dit tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'économie
je tiens aujourd'hui une grande idée
mais je pense est une mauvaise idée qui
est dire les départements vont devoir
faire face à des dépenses d'allocations
sociales conséquente donc il faut qu'ils
gardent leurs moyens financiers
le principe de base de l'action sociale
c'est la prévention avant de payer des
avocats
sion qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour que
les citoyens ne se retrouve pas dans ces
situations où on va devoir leur payer
une allocation pour les sortir de la
situation dans laquelle il se trouve
aide et nos départements il préférerait
avoir les souplesses qui leur permettent
d'agir en amont et notamment dans
l'économie de proximité pour pouvoir
offrir des possibilités aux gens de ce
solvabiliser plutôt que de leur verser
des allocations même si ce notre mission
sociale on l'a sur de façon bien sûr
pleine et entière
concernant la voilà pour cette audition
de dominique bussereau cette question à
présent faut-il moderniser nos
infrastructures du numérique et si oui
de quelle façon martin bouygues est
auditionné par la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire à l'ordre du
jour notamment le déploiement de la 5g
regarder nous vous accueillons ce matin
dans le cadre des auditions que nous
menons sur les conséquences du coc vite
19 et l'aménagement numérique du
territoire
nous avons déjà reçu le ministre julien
de normandie le président de l'arcep les
les référents que nous avons nommé sur
les questions d'aménagement numérique du
territoire pendant la crise à savoir
patrick chaize qui doit être avec nous
mais à distance
jean-michel houlgate qui était présent
et ben yeoh chevrier qui est également
là ont de leur côté entendu la
fédération française des
télécommunications et je crois
l'ensemble des opérateurs dont bouygues
telecom alors c'est la première fois
qu'on a le plaisir de vous accueillir et
on a souhaité vous accueillir à la suite
d'une tribune que vous avez fait
paraître il y a maintenant quelques
jours et qui
a fait grand bruit puisque vous appeler
à un report des enchères de la 5g
compte tenu de la crise sanitaire
je voudrais juste rappeler quelques
éléments de calendrier sur la 5g en
avril dernier
chacun des quatre opérateurs a pu
acquérir un bloc de 50 méga hertz a
appris de 350 millions d'euros à la
suite de cette attribution les
fréquences restant devaient être
attribués aux enchères par bloc de dix
mégahertz un prix plancher de 70
millions d'euros par bloc a été fixé par
l'état portant le montant total de
l'attribution des fréquences 5 g à un
niveau minimum de 2,17 milliards d'euros
cette seconde phase d'enchères donc a
été reportée compte tenu de la crise
devait avoir lieu au printemps
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement prévoit
cette attribution soit au mois de
juillet soit au mois de septembre
vous avez dans la tribune que j'évoquais
affirmé qu'il serait souhaitable de
décaler ses enchères à la fin de l'année
2020 voire au début de l'année 2000 21
les fréquences 5g n'étant pas genou site
une urgence pour la france et vous
appuyez notamment sur le fait que les
usages innovants n'arriveront de toute
manière pas avant 2023 ou 2024
vous avez également souligné que dans un
certain nombre de pays dont le nôtre
d'ailleurs il ya une espèce de défiance
de l'opinion publique vis-à-vis de la 5g
je crois qu'il ya même eu un certain
nombre de dégradations qui ont été
observées en grande bretagne il y a
effectivement et on en parle de plus en
plus un impact de la 5g qui est souligné
aussi bien sur le plan sanitaire
sur le plan environnemental et je ne
doute pas que sur le gâteau monsieur
chevrollier en parlerons puis son
rapporteur de la mission d'information
sur l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique est aussi des questions qui se
posent sur la question de la
souveraineté c'est pour ça que certains
ont vu dans dans vos interventions le
fait que
craindre y y et que l'un d'eux s'ils
interdisent d'utiliser des équipements
chinois qui sont je crois ce qui sont
utilisés par les meules à la génération
de mobiles précédente
vous appelez donc à la réalisation d'un
new deal 2 vous nous expliquerez en quoi
cela est nécessaire puisque aujourd'hui
on a un new deal qui n'est pas encore
aboutie qu il est en phase de mise en
oeuvre et qui d'ailleurs se met en
oeuvre sans doute assez lentement et de
manière dont on peut craindre qu'il ne
soit pas totalement respectée voilà
quelques points sur lesquels nous
souhaiterions vous entendre monsieur le
président je laisserais ensuite la
parole aux veaux référent de la mission
d'information et l ensemble de mes
collègues qui souhaiteront s'exprimer
sachant que nous avons une heure et demi
devant nous donc vrac les questions soit
brève mes chers collègues ce président
week je laisse la parole je le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord vous vous remercie de m'avoir
invité avec du verrou sac d'être général
délégué du groupe bouygues et didier
casas et puis spécifiquement bouygues
telecom à m'exprimer donc devant votre
commission aujourd'hui je le fais un
moment particulier puisque le pays se
relève avec difficulté de cette terrible
crise du coc vite 19 les conséquences
sur l'économie sont évidemment très
importante et je le crains on n'a pas
fini encore de tout voir je souhaiterais
avant de répondre à vos questions vous
présenter rapidement les conséquences de
la crise sur le groupe bouygues
les dispositions que nous avons prises
pour faire face aux difficultés et les
quelques mesures que nous pensons être
utile pour accélérer la couverture
mobile du territoire alors en tout
premier lieu les conséquences de la
crise sur les différents métiers du
groupe et bien les résultats du premier
trimestre publiés le 14 mai dernier
permettent de mesurer les premières
conséquences de la pandémie sur les
finances de notre groupe ce que nous
sommes a des très rares groupe français
a publié des comptes trimestriels la
différence des autres
les comptes semestriels pour l'ensemble
du groupe
nous estimons que la baisse de chiffre
d'affaires lié aux copies de 19,16 à
environ 750 millions d'euros au premier
trimestre 2009 1 avec petite partie du
mois de mars dont 600 millions d'euros
environ sur la france la france
concentre donc 80% de l'impact financier
du coc vite sur les finances du groupe
c'est qu'est nettement plus que les 60 %
que représente la france dans notre
chiffre d'affaires global distorsion
force est de constater que notre pays
est celui dans lequel le ralentissement
d'activité a été le plus fort et le plus
long le voyons très nettement
aujourd'hui en phase de sortie de crise
la plupart des pays du monde dans
lesquelles nous opérons environ 52 pays
à travers le monde ont repris presque
normalement corps de son côté la france
marque encore le padrosa d'activité les
métiers sont diversement affecté par
cette baisse étant donné la nature des
activités ce sont les métiers du pôle
construction promotion immobilière route
et construction qui ont subi le plus
gros impact avec une baisse d'environ
700 millions d'euros sur les 750
cette baisse s'explique par la quasi
arrêt des chantiers en france à partir
du 17 mars et le ralentissement ou
l'arrêt des chantiers donc bien nombreux
pays forte heureusement cependant les
atouts traditionnels du groupe lui
permettent d'être très bien positionnés
pour ne prendre aucun repas en sortie de
caisse d'une part la structure
financière du groupe est restée très
saine nous sommes en effet un groupe
très peu endetté le groupe dispose
d'environ 10 milliards d'euros de
trésorerie disponibles à fin mars
dernier donc une situation confortable
d'autre part la grande qualité du
dialogue social dans tous les métiers du
groupe ainsi que les décisions que nous
avons prises ont permis de limiter au
maximum les conséquences sur les
collaborateurs et de mettre en place les
conditions d'une réponse rapide
alors je vous parle maintenant de la
disposition que nous avons prises la
première de mes préoccupations étaient
évidemment dès le début de la crise de
prendre immédiatement toutes les
dispositions pour préserver la santé de
nos collaborateurs c'est évidemment très
légitime à chaque fois que cela a été
possible en fonction du métier nous
avons mis en place le télétravail
naturellement cela s'est révélé
impossible pour certaines activités
je pense particulièrement aux
journalistes qui doivent évidemment se
déplacer pour préparer les journaux
télévisés faire les reportages ainsi que
les techniciens qui travaillent avec eux
qui doivent être présents physiquement
pour assurer la maintenance du réseau
pour la téléphonie ou pour tf1 pour tous
et cela et pour tous les collaborateurs
qui depuis quelques jours reviennent
progressivement sur le lieu de travail
nous avons préparé des procédures
sanitaires très complète parfois
complexes et mis à disposition j'ai la
dent j'ai les droits le coliques masque
thermomètre etc comme il était
impossible d'acquérir en france jusqu'à
une date récente se démarque nous sommes
organisés pour en acheter en asie nous
avons effectivement des acheteurs en
asie depuis 50 ans et donc les équipes
achats de la filiale bouygues
construction ont acheté au total 45
millions de masques pour les besoins de
tous les collaborateurs du groupe et
nous avons comme il était naturel fait
preuve de solidarité en donnant un
million de masques aux établissements de
santé dès le début de la crise et aussi
à nous avons fait de même en côte
d'ivoire parce que nous sommes un vieux
partenaires de la côte d'ivoire depuis
très longtemps et nous avons fait aussi
un million de masques à la côte d'ivoire
pour l'aider dans la gestion de la crise
par ailleurs nous avons aussi met à
disposition de petits sous traitants de
fournisseurs de petits fournisseurs des
masses parce qu'eux mêmes avaient du mal
à s'en procurer
et pour les aider à redémarrer
confronté à l'arrêt total de l'activité
dans certains métiers de nous avons dû
nous poser la question du chômage
partiel et sur ce sujet nous avons pris
deux décisions fortes
d'une part contrairement à d'autres
groupes nous avons limité au maximum le
nombre de collaborateurs concernés au
pire de la crise nous avons pas eu plus
de 26 % des effectifs français du groupe
en chômage partiel
l'essentiel des collaborateurs concernés
étaient chez colas métiers de la route
bouygues construction et bouygues
immobilier en raison de l'arrêt total
des chantiers de 26 % le taux de chômage
partiel est tombé à 12 % dès le mois de
mai est maintenant à 15 00 au mois de
juin
d'autre part nous avons pris la décision
de neutraliser au maximum l'impact
financier du chômage partiel pour les
collaborateurs chez bouygues
construction colas tf1 et bouygues
telecom la perte de salaire due au
chômage partiel du mois de mars a été
intégralement compensée c'est bouygues
immobilier le chômage partiel n'a
commencé qu'en avril et la perte de
rémunération a été compensée à 90%
l'important est maintenant d'accélérer
le plus possible en représailles si vite
et dans la construction par exemple le
problème n'est pas le carnet de
commandes déjà très fourni et la
nécessité de rattraper le retard
accumulé pendant le confinement
nous avons négocié très vite avec nos
partenaires sociaux un accord qui permet
de réduire la longueur des vacances
d'été est donc ce trois semaines
consécutives maximum avec une
recommandation à 2 afin d'accroître le
nombre de jours pouvant être placés sur
le compte épargne temps et d'augmenter
le nombre d'heures travaillées jusqu'au
maximum légal dans les activités comme
le btp qui sont fortement saisonnière il
faut absolument tirer le maximum de
l'été pour tenter de rattraper une
partie du retard pris pendant
confinement
alors maintenant qu'est ce que nous
pensons nécessaire pour la reprise
d'activité comme j'ai l'honneur de
m'exprimer devant la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire je voudrais
évidemment concentrer mon propos sur la
question relative à la couverture mobile
des territoires et à la singer comme
vous le savez j'ai fait il ya quelques
jours vous l'avait gentiment rappelé une
proposition concernant la 5g la
couverture des territoires je voudrais
vous exposer en quelques mots le sens de
ses propositions
le raisonnement est simple il tient en
plusieurs étapes
première étape j'affirme que retarder
des enchères 5g de cinq ou six mois ne
pose aucun problème pour la
compétitivité de l'économie française
la 5g que les opérateurs vont déployer
dans un premier temps n'aura pour seul
intérêt que de permettre une éventuelle
des saturations très local des mobiles
des réseaux mobiles 4g lorsqu'ils sont
saturées ce que quelqu un qu elle
servira donc dans les grands centres
urbains et de façon très ponctuelle
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de trafic mobile
et donc ça servira à rendre les
communications plus fluide ce n'est qu'à
partir de 2023 que la maturité
progressive de la 5g et l'arrivée d'une
seconde vague d'équipement permettra
d'envisager de nouveaux usages notamment
industriels grâce à des débits plus
élevés et un faible taux de latence
le gain pour la compétitivité sera
réelle mais à ce moment là seulement le
fait de faire les enchères en décembre
2020 plutôt qu'en septembre 2020 donc me
semble pas être un grand problème
la deuxième étape c'est que la vérité
m'oblige à dire que pour l'instant un
nombre croissant de français exprime au
mieux de la différence ou pire de la
méfiance pour la 5 juin je sais si ce
qu'ils vous disent sur le terrain mais
nous entendons pour notre part beaucoup
de discours négatif à ce sujet ces
discours repose sur deux thèmes le
développement durable et les effets des
ondes
de ces deux sujets je crois qu'il est
nécessaire de parler dans un débat
public sera éclairé avant de faire les
enchères je ne dis pas cela pour gagner
du temps mais simplement parce que je
pense que c'est important de ne pas
escamoter le débat public sur la
technologie
c'est un débat qui va semble être
légitime manifestement le gouvernement a
décidé que ce débat devait pas avoir
lieu j'ai noté qu'avant même que je
puisse m'exprimer devant vous
aujourd'hui
la secrétaire d'état a exprimé dans une
interview samedi
les enchères auront lieu en septembre et
qu'il était hors de question
selon elle d'ouvrir une discussion cet
empressement est un peu curieux je n'ai
pas la même conception du débat
démocratique
quoi qu'il en soit jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est à la recette que revient
la décision et je me dis que le
parlement a aussi le droit de savoir
la troisième étape ce que je constate
que les français restent globalement
assez insatisfait par la couverture qui
reste insuffisante des territoires les
opérateurs ont beaucoup déployé dans les
zones blanches je considère que le new
deal est un instrument utile et efficace
mais manifestement il reste à faire je
pense d'ailleurs que le confinement a
bien montré ce besoin il n'a fait
qu'accentuer le besoin puisque des
français se sont trouvés confinés dans
des zones qui ne sont pas l'ordre zone
principale ayant non parfois souffert
c'est pour ces pour il faut donc à mon
sens aller plus loin et plus vite
c'est pourquoi je propose que les
opérateurs construisent 15 cents même
2000 site mutualisé supplémentaires dans
les prochaines années en plus de ceux
qui ont déjà été construits dans le
cadre du new deal
nous pourrions nous mettre d'accord sous
l'égide de l'arcep bien entendu sur la
meilleure façon de réaliser ce programme
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de repousser les enchères de
quelques mois pour avoir le temps de
renégocier un accord de la balle et les
quelques centaines de milliers
nécessaire à cet investissement nouveau
serait évidemment à prendre en
considération sur le montant des
redevances payées au titre des
fréquences 5les c'est un système simple
efficace financée qui se propose de
répondre à la demande des territoires
apparemment le gouvernement pense que ce
n'est pas nécessaire et bercy par la
voix de madame pas dire une enchère la
rejeter
j'en prends acte comme nous l'avons
toujours dit bouygues telecom se portera
acquéreur de fréquences 5 g même si
évidemment les enchères ont lieu au mois
de septembre
en revanche il doit être clair pour tout
le monde que si par hasard et venait à
l'idée des pouvoirs publics
après les enchères après que les
enchères auront eu lieu de demander aux
opérateurs de faire un effort
supplémentaire pour la couverture des
territoires dans le cadre d'un nouveau
programme zones blanches supposant des
investissements des opérateurs
notre réponse sera forcément assez
réservés nous serons alors rappelé à la
ministre ou à son successeur qu'il y
avait un levier pour améliorer
efficacement les choses et le financer
voilà je me tiens été collaborateur
merci beaucoup je t en premier lieu de
donner lieu donc donner la parole pardon
ou référents sur la couverture numérique
et à patrick chaize qui doit être en
ligne
le chef vous nous entendez monsieur
chaize
vous imaginez qu'il ait une mauvaise
connexion très bien monsieur chaize on
vous entend et en même on va vous
écouter
[Musique]
merci à vibrer
je réagis évidemment à pire est
peut-être reprendre certains éléments de
votre discussion parce que on peut lire
je veux dire que certains de vos
arguments sont les biens et je vais
partage
mais lorsqu'on a sûrement vos
divergences de l'analyse est en tout cas
de programmation donc votre directeur
général depuis télécom même si je vienne
dans les échos que le nouveau new deal
qui vous appelez de vos voeux pourrait
être gagée par un ajustement des
conditions 5 g je cite si seul utile 2
permet de dépenser un peu moins sur la
scène j ai un peu plus sur la 4g sur la
volga pour moi dépensé sur la 5g ya deux
solutions soit l'état réduit le prix
plancher fixé par les enchères soit le
cahier des charges fixant les
obligations de couverture et à ce petit
jeu très que vous donniez la solution
que vous privilégiez s'ils téléchargent
fixé par l'arcep et est assouplie nous
savons très bien ce que cela va
signifier ce atifi probablement des
ambitions de couverture samedi est
moindre dans les territoires alors nous
serine l'ajustement des conditions
délivrance des fréquences 5g
consiste-t-il a renoncé au déploiement
de la 5g dans les territoires peu denses
d'après vous le prix à payer pour la 4g
deschamps doit-il être de circonscrire
la 5g
à l'avenir je ne partage pas ce point de
vue les enjeux les plans de la 4g aidé à
5g doivent être dissociée qu'on allait
rappeler le président n'aurait vous êtes
langagier déjà moyennant un effort
financier de l'état à garantir une
couverture 4g sur l'ensemble territoire
connu dit que ce soir la généralisation
de la 4g sur les sites existants ou par
le dispositif des couvertures ciblés
concernant le dispositif de couverture
cible et je constate d'ailleurs que les
déploiements ont pas été totalement
arrêtées et que les pilotes ont continué
à exiger on a les documents ce type pour
très posé
guru réjouir de cette situation et
remercier l'ensemble des équipes de
terrain pour le travail effectué malgré
ces efforts il est certain que la crise
sanitaire a ralenti les déploiements
il y aura sans aucun doute des retards
ce qui est parfaitement compréhensible
je rappelle cependant que des doutes
avaient été émis a quand même les
débutants pigments canton respect de ces
échéances
seuls des retards qui te ment justifiée
par la notaire seront donc tolérés par
l'état c'est ce qu'a rappelé le ministre
il ya quelques jours devant d'autres
commissions le ministre nous a également
affirmé t opérateur ou un homme
extrêmement et de fonds présent très
très rapidement un état des lieux
d'avancement de lully condé réussite du
dispositif de couverture cible et serez
vous en mesure de livrer fin juin et
parmi les retards qui seront constatés
combien sont strictement justifiée par
la crise sanitaire et la période de
confinement étaient légion je vais
remercier monsieur chaize j'ai donné la
parole aux deux autres références
houlgate et monsieur chevrollier comme
ça le prénom bouygues répondra
globalement à cette première série
d'intervenants monsieur l'uqat
oui merci monsieur le président merci de
vous être déplacés ici dans l'enceinte
du sénat pour rencontrer donc les
membres de la commission aménagement du
territoire vous nous avez parlé donc des
premiers chiffres que vous avez libéré
sur la perte du chiffre d'affaires pour
les trois premiers mois
est-ce que vous avez une projection sur
l'ensemble de l'année 2020 puisque fin
de compte sur l'ensemble de l'année 2020
on aura malheureusement des mois qui
seront beaucoup plus pénalisant que que
les trois premiers de l'année
ma question va porter bien évidemment
dans le prolongement de ce qui a été dit
notamment par rapport à la 5g
est ce que vous avez vous de votre côté
au niveau du groupe fait ou c'est qu'on
s'intéresse beaucoup et le président l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure sur l'impact
environnemental du numérique le
numérique est un facteur de croissance
mais ça a été aussi pendant cette crise
un formidable vecteur de résilience et
on l'a vu la permet la continuité
d'activité économique éducative
parfois en termes de santé ou tout
simplement en termes de de lien social
mais il a aussi un impact
environnemental à la fois sur la
consommation énergétique qui sont liées
aux acheminement des trafics et puis
aussi bien évidemment sur sur les
équipements notamment les équipements
les différentes composantes qui permet
justement de fabriquer ses équipements
est-ce que vous avez vous fait une étude
un peu sur l'impact environnemental que
pourrait avoir la 5g on sait que les
choses sont contrastées certains nous
disent il y aura des économies d'un côté
mais de l'autre côté le renouvellement
total des équipements fera qu' on sera
obligé de consommer à nouveau des
matières premières dans quelle est votre
opinion là dessus et puis point
peut-être un peu plus un peu plus
technique c'est à dire que la loi qui
vise à sécuriser les futurs réseaux 5g
vous oblige donc à obtenir une
autorisation de landecy pour être en
mesure d'utiliser des équipements 5g de
fournisseurs avec lesquels vous
souhaitez travailler donc où est ce que
vous en êtes vous de vous demande
d'autorisation auprès de landecy ce que
vous avez reçu une réponse
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer
là dessus merci beaucoup merci monsieur
viennent je rappelle d'ailleurs que la
commission organise le 1er juillet ici
même une table ronde à kehl les
opérateurs participant bien sûr sur
l'impact environnemental du numérique
monsieur chevrollier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président en
briques c'est toujours très intéressant
de recevoir un grand patron français y
aurait beaucoup de questions abordées
sur vos activités dans dans le btp sous
vos activités à l'international sur la
couverture mobile du territoire mais je
vais limiter mais mes questions au sujet
du jour là la 5g et conformément aux
dispositions de la loi sur la sécurité
des réseaux 5 j'ai voté en out 2019 vous
avez saisies l'agencé nationale de
sécurité des systèmes d'information
d'une demande d'autorisation
d'exploitation des équipements du
chinois huawei
la réponse de l'agent ce n'a pas été
publié encore à ce jour et en février
dernier vous avez prévenu que vous
ne tolérerait pas d'impact financier
négatif ni de désavantage concurrentiel
qui découlerait d'une éventuelle
interdiction totale ou partielle de
huawei votre secrétaire général ici
présents avaient confirmé que vous
réserviez toute possibilité pour
protéger vos droits et voire un recours
juridique contre les décrets
d'application de la loi de 2019 est ce
que vous maintenez cette position et ne
pensez vous pas que la donne a changé
avec la crise sanitaire voyant le
royaume uni qui avait un temps donné lui
aussi son feu vert sous condition à
huawei a réduit aujourd'hui la
participation dans ses infrastructures
5g selon des informations relayées dans
la presse britannique
en effet aujourd'hui on a une méfiance
de plus en plus importante vis-à-vis de
la chine qui a manqué de transparence on
cadre de la crise du coc vide 19
est ce que ce ne pourrait pas avoir
aussi d une influence sur l'accès à
cette technologie par huawei sur réseau
5g européen
à l'heure où la question de la
souveraineté technologique est dans le
débat public français
quelle réaction par rapport à ça
j'aimerais aussi abordé la question des
impacts sanitaires et environnementaux
de la 5g vous l'avez évoqué sur les
dégradations des pylônes et la
circulation de deux thèses complotistes
associant d'ailleurs la 5g avec la crise
sanitaire dont il ya un climat de
défiance croissant lançait sa réalise
actuellement des travaux il nécessaire
et vous l'avez dit de rationaliser ce
débat là ne cessent a fait savoir
qu'elle avait des difficultés à accéder
à certaines données détenues par les
opérateurs et qu'il y avait encore un
certain nombre de zones d'ombré est-ce
que
pouvez nous confirmer que votre groupe
transmettre toutes les informations
alan cesse afin de pouvoir permettre un
déploiement apaisée de la 5g et là aussi
comme vous l'avez dit qu'il ya un débat
public avec toute la transparence qui
doit s'imposer pour lutter contre les
fausses informations qui sont très
nombreuses aujourd'hui mais enfin votre
groupe réfléchit et il a des solutions
concrètes pour limiter les impacts
environnementaux du numérique et en
particulier des réseaux et certaines
pistes concrètes pourraient être
étudiées concernant par exemple les box
internet qui sont votre propriété ne
faudrait-il pas par exemple systématiser
des technologies de mise en veille
automatique des box ou réfléchir une
meilleure mutualisation de ses
équipements dans les habitats collectifs
d'ailleurs que vous réalisez par
ailleurs et enfin la généralisation de
la 4g et l'arrivée d'un 5 g devrait ne
devrait pas pousser à planifier une
extension progressive des anciennes
générations de mobiles
merci beaucoup monsieur présent week je
vous propose de répondre déjà cette
favela version et christian juste eux on
est tous d'accord sur une idée mais je
voudrais quand même là réagir mais c'est
que tout ce que les opérateurs dépenses
en termes d'investissements que ce soit
des achats de fréquences des équipements
de toutes sortes une fille n'ait cédé
consommateurs qui les paye c'est à dire
les français en général c'est juste un
petit rappel mais on est tous d'accord
là dessus mais c'est juste pour bien
préciser les choses parce que je pense
que il faut savoir que cette saison
parle de sommes quand même prendre
hâtivement très importante
vous avez un certain nombre de questions
sur le respect du new deal les débats
kadjé 5g je vais laisser olivier roussat
qui est aussi le président directeur
général de bouygues telecom et didier
casas de vos réponses
mais reprendre un peu vos questions en
démarrant par la première marque nous a
été fait à distance bien évidemment nous
sommes assez consistants dans la
chronique fin dans l'article que martin
avait publié bien évidemment si nous
souhaitons favoriser la couverture des
territoires et rajouter des sites
supplémentaires en zone blanche pour
apporter la couverture 4g
bien évidemment nous ne sommes pas en
train de demander un ralentissement du
cadencement du déploiement de la 5g
puisque ça voudrait dire qu'on vous
demande de chose et son contraire ce qui
n'est pas du tout l'esprit de ce qu'on
est en train de vous demander on est
simplement en train de dire que de façon
très claire sur le territoire et les
autres non couverte qui sont apparus à
ces critiques dans cette période qui
nous paraît nécessaire de rajouter
quelques milliers de sites en inde
blanche et de pouvoir défalquer le coût
de ces sites supplémentaires du fameux
socle qui a été prévu en début d'année
et nous ne remettons absolument pas en
cause le rythme et le cadencement qui
nous est demandé des licences 5g tel
qu'il est exprimée dans les licences
telles qu'elles sont écrites à l'heure
actuelle puisque nous ne souhaitons pas
du tout avoir une kadji les campagnes
une 5g des vignes c'est parce qu'on
demande
on dit simplement il faut renforcer la
couverture du territoire et pour
renforcer cette couverture on croit que
le nombre de sites supplémentaires
s'exprime probablement en milliers et
qu'il ya lieu d'en parler pendant
quelques temps c'est la raison pour
laquelle on souhaitait décalé cet appel
d'offres pouvoir en tenir compte dans le
calcul du socle puisque c'est bien du
socle dont il était question pour qu'on
puisse aller des facs et je rappelle
qu'à l'art à l'heure à laquelle nous
parlons à date nous n'avons rien payer
du tout puisque le paiement effectif du
fameux socle qui est présenté comme
étant acquis depuis le début cette année
à la suite d'une déclaration de
sébastien soriano ne se concrétise en
paiement qu'au moment où nous avons
déroulé les enchères véritable donc
c'est quelque chose qui sera de toute
façon dans plusieurs mois donc pour
répondre à la première question
très clairement nous ne souhaitons pas
remettre en cause le cadencement des 6 2
5g nous souhaitons simplement augmenter
le nombre de sites disponibles en zone
blanche dont je vous rappelle que nous
avons une obligation de les transformer
en 4g et dont je vous rappelle et c'est
un élément de réponse dans ce que vous
avez demandé pour new deal notre
obligation était d'avoir 75 % décidée
zones blanches
poussé par bouygues telecom qui soit
disponible en 4 g à la fin de cette
année nous serons à plus de 80% de la
même façon on peut pas prétendre dans
une rubrique qu'il faut donner plus de
couverture et ne pas apporter ce
supplément de couverture dans la
migration des sites 4g qui sont sous
notre responsabilité à nous on est assez
consistants on est bien en train de dire
qu'on croit qu'il faut mettre plus
d'internet pour que les clients puissent
être que les français d'une façon
générale puisse accéder à internet ce
qu'on a bien vu dans l'appel de
confinement que si on n'a pas accès
internet on n'a pas accès au télétravail
on n'a pas accès à la télé éducation on
n'a pas accès à la télémédecine on n'a
pas accès à tout un tas de choses qui
ont littéralement explosé dont on a
compris véritablement l'intérêt à
l'occasion du confinement un sujet aussi
simple que la télémédecine que la
téléconsultation avant le confinement
n'y avait pas téléconsultation après le
confinement c'est presque devenu la
norme
donc on est quand même en train de dire
on croit que les habitudes qui ont été
prises lens confinement soit dhabi pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles sont
durables et nous devons offrir plus de
connectivité pour y parvenir on a une
occasion il ya un mode de financement
qui existe qui est assez simple et donc
discutons quelques semaines pour
discuter de l'envelope supplémentaires
que l'on donne et des méthodes qui
permettront de l'attribuer département
par département on a une occasion donc
autant en profiter maintenant
directement encore une fois il s'agit
d'être consistant avec ce que l'on a mis
au travers de la rubrique qui avait été
qu'il était proposée par martin voyer
deuxième sujet
l'impact environnemental il y a
cet argument est utilisé de façon très
fréquentes pour expliquer que la 5g
quelque chose qui consomme moins que la
4g et ont fini par dire des choses
vraies qui sont fausses ou des choses
fausses qui peuvent apparaître vrai
qu'en est il exactement
la 5g permet lorsqu'on transporte des
datas de les transporter avec moins
d'énergie mais la 5g parce qu'elle
augmente considérablement les débits
nous permet d'avoir un usage beaucoup
plus important quand on a un usage
beaucoup plus important on transporte
beaucoup plus d'attaqués quand on
transporte beaucoup plus tard même si
unitairement c'est un poil moins cher
c'est beaucoup plus consommateurs que ce
que c'était précédemment
donc nous dire que quand on est en 5 g
on va donc permettre de faire des effort
environnemental la consommation énergie
ça n'est pas vrai quand on mesurera la
consommation énergétique de tous les
opérateurs
au bout d'un an on la verra en
augmentation de façon importante on a
dans le groupe pris l'engagement de
communiquer à la fin de cette année pour
l'ensemble des métiers du groupe
bouygues delà de la rom delà du tragique
l'on prend du plan d'action que l'on se
donne pour être conforme à l'accord de
paris et être capables de réduire nos
émissions à gaz à effet de serre d'ici à
quand on prend spécifiquement la
situation de boules télécom qui est une
des divisions de bouygues
très concrètement sur l'énergie on n'a
pas la pierre philosophale ce que l'on
sait c'est que de toute façon notre
consommation d'énergie elle va augmenter
parce que dès que l'on donne une
capacité d' usage de trafic supérieure à
nos clients bell l'utilisent c'est bien
normal d'ailleurs ces mêmes l'esprit
avec lequel on leur donne et que à la
fin des fins l'augmentation est réelle
en termes de consommation sur les sujets
et j'en viens d'ailleurs sur ce sujet
sur l'impact environnemental des boks
qui était la dernière question c'est
juste pour pouvoir le couvrir de
dans ce petit sujet on vient de sortir
il y a deux semaines on a fait une
annonce
on a bien conscience du fait qu'il faut
réduire le nombre d'équipements
électroniques qu'ils consomment parce
que plus on met à disposition
d'équipements électroniques consomme et
plus évidemment la consommation est
importante on vient et on a été le
premier opérateur à le faire en france
est même l'un des premiers au monde à
loger à utiliser les téléviseurs tels
qu'ils sont et à mettre un morceau de
logiciels dans le téléviseur qui nous
évite de rajouter la boîte que l'on
mettait au pied de la télévision la
fameuse box ce sujet nous permet de
régler le problème la consommation de la
boxe il a plu ça quand on enlève ça on
est sûr qu'elle consomme moins
puisqu'elle n'existe plus ce genre de
choses c'est là c'est le chemin que nous
prenons pour aller dans le sens de ce
que vous dites et on règle la même façon
le problème de la mise en veille lorsque
quand vous arrêtez votre télévision
si les français alors après ils peuvent
ne pas vouloir arrêter la télévision
mais s'agit peut pas grand chose les
mines c'est vraiment un usage il faudra
qu'on éduque nos concitoyens pour être
capable de le faire précisément pour
aller dans ce sens de ce que vous avez
dit et bien une bonne façon de gérer la
consommation d box et les supprimer il
n'y a pas de boxe aux moyens pas de
consommation qu'ils soient générés par
par la boxe et le surplus le logiciel
que l'on fait tourner dans la télévision
il a le mérite plus de ne pas consommer
quoi que ce soit de ne pas faire
consommer quoi que ce soit de plus au
téléviseur sur le dispositif ciblé où en
sommes-nous on avait trois points de
passage qui était prévu on avait un
point de passage le 27 juin qui avec les
décrets dont je ne connais pas le détail
nous permettrait théoriquement d'avoir
trois mois une semaine de plus pour
pouvoir les tenir nous devions produire
sans incident
le 27 juin nous livrerons 70 sites dans
les 70 sites qu'on va livrer il y en a
trente qui vont tourner sur des groupes
électrogènes
parce que eni 10 n'a pas pu nous mettre
à disposition l'alimentation électrique
qui permettait de faire tourner lorsque
nous avons négocié new deal il ya un
point sur lequel nous avions beaucoup
insisté auprès de l'arcep
il est pour simplifier les méthodes de
déploiement c'est notre métier de monter
des pylônes personne ne le conteste en
revanche l'acheminement électrique par
des syndicats d'électrification
les quelque chose qui est parfois
compliqué parce que l'emplacement qui
nous est donnée est parfois loin de la
commune
quand vous avez une tranchée d'un
kilomètre et demi de kilomètres pour
amener le courant dans une zone qu'il
n'a pas c'est pas forcément quelque
chose de simple là de façon très
concrète nous avons sur les poissons
d'ici trente sites qui vont tourner sur
des groupes électrogènes en termes de
consommation environnementale et
l'impact environnemental et de
consommation d'énergie
on a fait un peu mieux puisque je
rappelle que les groupes électrogènes ce
sont des moteurs thermiques qui tourne
24 7 alors il se trouve qu'en
l'occurrence ça gêne pas grand monde
autour parce que le plus souvent ils
sont dans des zones qui sont peu habitée
mais c'est une conséquence très concrète
de ce qui vient de se passer
nous n'avons pas eu la capacité à
pouvoir faire venir l'électricité à
temps pour autant on ouvre bien ces
sites
les 31 sites qui manquent seront livrés
dans les trois mois qui viennent pour
ses 31 sites nous avons systématiquement
les raisons pour lesquelles nous n'avons
pas été capables de pouvoir réaliser
l'installation à temps nous avons pris
un nouvel engagement avec une fourniture
à la date qui a été indiqué de
l'ensemble de ses sites
je vous le redis sur le sujet de la 4g
notre engagement était à 75 %
il passera à 80 % comme seuil minimum on
a bon espoir d'être au delà de ça il
monte jusqu'à 85% sur la réalité de ce
qui s'est passé pendant le confinement
nous avons un certain nombre de
prestataires goûter des comme si une
société qui fait 7000 personnes
orange c'est 80 mille personnes en
france quand vous avez 7000 personnes et
que vous avez un métier qui se fait avec
une entreprise le même métier qu une
entreprise qui utilise 80 mille
personnes sachez que nous on sous traite
un certain nombre de choses parce que
par définition et 7000 je fais pas le
même travail quelque 4000 personnes et
donc la sous traitance dans les périodes
que nous avons connues de confinement on
a un ensemble d'entreprises qui n'ont
pas travaillé essentiellement pour être
conforme quand vous prenez un truc aussi
simple que le protocole sanitaire de
l'oppbtp qui est le protocole qui est
utilisé une société de télécoms fait
travailler des sociétés de construction
pour ériger des pylônes un pylône c'est
pas un métier de télécoms enfin ça
c'est partie prenante du métier télécoms
au sens où ça rend le service mais les
gens qui réalisent les pylônes sur les
sociétés c'est des filiales de bouygues
par exemple qui font ce genre de choses
fils à qui ça fait boum energy services
qui érigent des pylônes et qui fait le
socle en béton et qui amène extraits
cités c'est une activité bâtiment terre
c'est une activité qui était totalement
alignée sur la fourniture du protocole
sanitaire de l'oppbtp il a été fournis
début avril
dans ce protocole il était nécessaire de
fournir des masques de respecter
dissociation de m hydro alcoolique avoir
des points d'eau pour permettre aux
salariés de se laver les mains toutes
les deux heures enfin un certain nombre
de choses qui quand on les suit à la
lettre et à la règle de façon très très
précises sont quand même pas si simple
et donc effectivement nous avons perdu
un peu de temps sachez que à l'intérieur
de bouygues
nous avons repris nous nos activités
d'installation aux plans du bâtiment
c'est à dire quand je regarde les 70000
personnes qui en france sont
concrètement présente pour des activités
de bâtiment une route le 15 avril il ya
un mois effectivement pour des cas on
n'a pas travaillé parce que c'était
juste pas possible rappelle que le mot
d'ordre qui a été donnée le 17 mars et
que c'était la guerre et qui voulait
rester chez soi la peur était certaine
et des gens ne voulaient pas bougé donc
nous avons pris du retard
c'est indéniable nous rattraperons une
partie ce retard est en tout cas pour la
date du 27 juin que nous ne savons pas
faire
à l'heure actuelle nous ne sommes
toujours pas revenu à la normale
je vous rappelle que les conditions que
nous avons à l'heure actuelle pour les
travaux vous avez deux conditions qui
nous pénalise énormément on allie mca 30
qui fait qu'un salarié 15e ses trente
années mc2 lundi ce masque mal moi j'ai
un imc de 29
c'est une question de poids relatives à
la taille
si j'avais un hymne 7,30 il faut pas
beaucoup de kilos en plus 1,6 g 4 kg
plus c'est bon le médecin me demande de
rester chez moi parce que je ne peux pas
aller travailler parce que j'ai un
risque de comorbidité si j'attrape échos
vide
si vous rajoutez à ça le premier des
écoles ya quand même un centre
d'entreprises font pas peur démarrer
concrètement nous dans nos activités à
l'heure actuelle quand je prend nos
activités de promotion immobilière
on a que 85% des compagnons qui sont
présents sur les chantiers
imaginons pas que la france allait
reparti à 100% c'est pas vrai pour moi
jusqu'au 22 juin dans une situation où à
l'heure actuelle tout n'est pas reparti
la règle des 4 mètres carrés par
collaborateur dans un bâtiment ça vous
évite juste par deux les effectifs sur
les plateaux et donc il ya quand même
des choses qu'on sait pas faire au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous allons rattraper
nous rattraperons tout ce que nous
pouvons mais de façon explicite le 27
juin
nous ne sommes pas magicien en revanche
vous on mettra bien trente groupes
électrogènes mais il manquera 30 sites
qui arriveront dans les trois ans qui
suivent et ce n'est pas contradictoire
avec ce qu'on vous demande simplement
fait que le coc vide s'est imposé à nous
et nous n'avons pas su nous dire dans un
engagement social et je crois qu'il y
avait déjà des retards avant de covile
il faut pas tout faire supporter aux
cocos vide et aussi quand même un point
moi qui me qui m'interpelle dans tout ce
qui est dit depuis le début de
l'audition
c'est que le new deal doit alors gérer a
compris ce qui est possible
le new deal était censé régler le
problème global de couverture du
territoire en téléphonie mobile
c'est ce qui nous a été vendu par par
les pouvoirs publics
donc pour compléter un dispositif qui
était censé être complet c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît un peu étonnant
avant de laisser répondre sur le
rappeler un petit point j'étais
président une compagnie de distribution
d'eau la sorgue
à 35 ans donc je connais un peu le sujet
à ma connaissance pour l'eau potable
fait des lois que des législations qu'on
plus d'un siècle et tout le monde n'est
toujours pas toujours accordé bon donc
c'est simplement pour dire qu'il ya un
moment donné ou dans la collection
ultime ça devient extrêmement complexe
donc il reste effectivement quelques
maisons qui n'ont pas l'eau en france
mais enfin d'ici qu'on ait de la même la
même couverture en matière de téléphonie
mobile pour maquiller se passe pas un
certain temps mais le le plus chez
revient le plus sérieusement du monde
le présent la république quand il a été
élu je crois que c'était même mois de
jeu de mémoire ou de vienne a annoncé
que la question de la téléphonie mobile
serait réglé je cite dans les deux à
trois ans ok 2 à 3 ans sont écoulées
après on nous a mis en place le
dispositif du new deal et on nous
explique encore aujourd'hui que le new
deal va permettre de couvrir tout le
territoire téléphonie mobile et donc
vous faites une analyse différente si je
me suis présenté à apporter quelques
informations très très factuelle d'abord
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé le new
deal mobile est un tel qu'il a été
négocié en 2018 est un programme qui
s'étend sur de longue date qui se
termine je crois en 2025 ou 27 pour les
derniers objectifs premièrement
deuxièmement il est exact qu'il a été
présenté comme devant permettre la
couverture de l'ensemble du territoire
c'est tout à fait exact no - vous savez
nous nous sommes des gens assez
pragmatique ce que nous constatons c'est
quoi c'est que dans le principal
chantier du new deal mobile qui est le
dispositif de couverture ciblées pour
reprendre son petit nom technocratique
le guichet donc que vous connaissez bien
bien on constate tout simplement une
chose c'est que dans un territoire donné
lorsque il s'agit de couvrir les points
d'intérêt touristique les zones
d'activités économiques les zones à
couvrir en priorité telles qu'elles sont
définies par les équipes projet local
que vous connaissez tous ceux très bien
eh bien on s'aperçoit puisque dans ces
équipes projet local nous sommes
représentés et nous discutons avec avec
les élus avec vous même souvent nous
constatons que lorsque l'arrêté
ministériel a prévu sur une zone donnée
de prévoir
8 pylône dans le département de l'eure
qui vous est cher monsieur le président
eh bien on s'aperçoit que les
collectivités souvent nous disent non
mais attendez huit pilotes dans leurs
saynètes war menthe insuffisant ça sera
insuffisant pour couvrir l'intégralité
des zones que nous souhaitons voir
couvrir ça c'est un fait
c'est un fait incontestable et nous
souhaitons simplement répondre à ce
constat purement factuelle qui consiste
à dire que dans un certain nombre de
zones
les équipes projet local les élus les
citoyens remonte que le nombre de sites
prévus initialement n'est pas suffisant
pour répondre aux besoins et bien nous
lisons puisque ça n'est pas suffisant
alors créons un système qui permettra de
répondre de répondre sur ce point et
puis deuxième élément là encore purement
factuel que je voulais apporter
s'agissant du du new deal et du retard
supposé dans lequel nous aurions pu nous
trouver avant le confinement et plus
encore aujourd'hui je dirai les choses
là dessus très très très simplement le
ce qu'on appelle le lot 1 du dispositif
de couverture cible et dont les
compteurs doivent être relevés au 27
juin sur le lot 1
nous avions initialement nous boude
télécom 108 site a réalisé sur ce lot 1
retenu par arrêté ministériel dont on
est falke de mémoire site qui devait
être retirée par un arrêté modificatif
il en reste et 102 en fonction du
comptage sur ce nombre
avant le déclenchement du coc vide dans
le pointage quasi hebdomadaire que nous
faisons avec l'arcep bouygues telecom
avait déclaré qu'il serait à l'heure et
qu'il ouvrirait au 27 juin
101 ou 102 sites selon le bon chiffre
là-dessus il va être extrêmement clair
bout de télécom n'était pas en retard
sur le new deal mobile avant le
déclenchement du bolide nous le sommes
ensuite pour toutes les raisons que les
virus a exposé qui sont des raisons très
matérielle et que j'imagine tout le
monde peut bien comprendre
comme vous le savez aiguillonné
justement d'ailleurs par votre
commission et par l'ensemble des parties
prenantes
l'arcep examine les choses de façon
extrêmement précise
et nous a demandé de justifier site à
site ceux pour lesquels nous serons en
retard éventuellement à la fin de ce
mois nous le faisons mais j'affirme là
encore que bouygues telecom n'est pas
plus en retard que les autres opérateurs
s'agissant du dispositif de couverture
cible et nous serons à 70% en gros de
réalisation à part le cas d'orange qui
pour les raisons qui ont été expliquées
par ce que il a beaucoup plus de
collaborateurs directs que nous et
beaucoup moins dépendants de la sous
traitance ont donc beaucoup moins
affectés par le cos vide sera lui
légèrement plus en avance mais les trois
autres opérateurs nous compris nous
sommes à peu près dans la même plaque ce
qui montre bien d'ailleurs que il n'ya
pas d'utilisation du coc vide comme
étant un prétexte pour justifier des
retards on est comme tout le monde dans
ce pays assez durement affectée par le
ralentissement d'activité
voilà vous venez d'assister à l'audition
de martin boeing audition à laquelle il
a notamment été question du déploiement
de la 5g sur le territoire une question
plus que jamais d'actualité puisque le
nouveau réseau mobile sera commercialisé
en france à partir du mois de juillet
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi restez avec nous
l'information politique et parlementaire
continue sur notre antenne